[Music]
hi everyone this is bonus Grandmaster
subpoena for sure I'm here the San Luis
chess club and you're watching chess for
knights and last class I discussed some
of my games some of the bad things that
happen in my game some of the good
things that happen in my games so I'm
going to continue with that I have some
examples from my own games and hopefully
you will enjoy finding them so this is
the first position what do you think
about this position who is better yeah
white is better well y-yeah composition
coordination oh yeah you remember that's
good that's good yeah the pieces I did
short this position really no I think
last position was the one that it wasn't
this one it was not this one shouldn't
have been
I did shine okay if I showed you that's
good okay I don't remember showing you
this position maybe it was at the end of
the class or something and I clicked on
it okay
rook takes the pawn and then mate okay
but like if you were looking at the
position
you forgot about material right you look
at King safety but then you forgot to
mention material okay so let's go to the
next game then did I show you this
position too
okay because I was sure that that last
one was anyways let's see that what do
you think about this position someone
who didn't say anything I mean we just
started so yeah you
yes yes it's a draw
okay why twins okay
how does why win Oh someone's asking
whose turn it is that's good
who's trying to think it is it is black
smooth
should I give you black I lost I'm black
okay what's the move with which black
makes a la king of fate and why would
that be a draw King f8 after King f8
black is going to lose I think right
what does y do here f7 King takes f7
what do we do with the way to win come
on guys let's have some focus Bishop h6
King f7
thank you yeah here Bishop to g7 can I
take why not and I'm in the Box no I
will take the pawn the next move well
yes but if you play King f8 here can you
try to think for a better move for white
King g6 and then what's White's idea
next yeah you just want to play Bishop
h6 Bishop g7 or Bishop h6 f7 f8 Queen so
in this position can I take this pawn
what do you do now Bishop takes and then
the pommel promotes check checkmate will
come eventually yeah so what what is
happening IRA tries are you guys trying
to make me lose here no I'm trying look
like normally this position should be
winning for white why should this
position normally be winning for white
well White has two extra pawns and it's
a bishop of the same color endgame if
white blunders might be a draw but now
it's like to move guys guys it's black
to move in this position right so you
need to try to think of a way to make a
draw the good thing that you got already
from this position I was lost earlier
but my opponent push these pawns a
little bit too fast and thought that
okay my bishop will be dead so he will
be able to just win because I'll be in
zoogs Bank right in this position if I
move my Klink which is what you guys try
to do before the King just comes to g6
and then the pawn pushes and then
there's check and then it's over right
so the ID in this position is can only
be what yeah
well look look at this position for a
second the King is is restricting
White's King and also is restricting
this pawn from pushing and it stops
whites from playing Bishop h6 Bishop g7
to trade the bishop yeah of course if I
take here what's happening
I know but someone said this move before
and then Queen you can't stop that right
if you could give the bishop up away and
then win that one of course it would be
draw but if not you have no chance you
know even if the spawners push more back
and your King would have made it to h7
tube locate it
what was the problem why was white still
winning because the bishop is of the
same color of the corner of the pawn the
marginal pawn so even if the pawn was
more pushed back and the King would have
made it in front you would have just
made it here not in the corner even if
it didn't the corner this bishop would
restrict it so what did we say we play
in this position to make a draw Bishop
g7 very good this is the move and the
problem the White has now is that if you
take then we take back and then we win
the pawn draw right so what about if
white just stays here for example my
opponent played in this position Bishop
h4 but what would happen if you just
stay
yes
do we agree and now what is blacks
threat taking f6 maybe first and then
taking h7 or do you want to just take in
h7 like if I would play that would you
take an h7 or would you take an f6 first
f6 would make it quite simple draw if
you take King takes h7 here
can white win let's try to figure this
thing out how do you win with white
let's hear it okay let's play play with
black Bishop f8
okay so in order for Y to win what does
white need to succeed to do to get the
bishop out of the way okay how will he
do that
yeah
this should be seven okay so we cannot
take obviously so we're going to move
the bishop out of the way bishop fa
bishop takes effect yes white cannot
promote at this point so if white wants
to promote they need to get rid of this
bishop from controlling the pawn yes
that's nice but and nobody forces me to
take your Bishop right I can just move
it
yes you can do that certainly yes so if
black makes the mistake of staying with
the bishop on this Agra know how can
white win yes
Bishop e2 Bishop e2 you're closing the
action of this bishop and then the pawn
will promote so after King d7 black
cannot make that mistake so what about
if he goes over here hmm you attack it
again again he cannot go there so he has
to go here and now what do you do now
you can try to bring your bishop here to
trade it but as soon as you bring your
bishop in here to trade it black will
just move away and now you cannot
promote and if you try to just move the
bishop away to promote black will move
with their Bishop on this other diagonal
right and now you need to do something
really really fun yes
Bishop f8 you are again locating your
pawn so you cannot progress you need to
figure out on which square you need to
trade this Bishop in order to be able to
win this end game which which one you
can do that okay
then we'll try to bring our Bishop on
this side right because the bishop would
take so now black switch the position of
his skin it's very tricky
these bishop end games are very tricky
you have to play it that though a really
long time in order to try to win with
white and if you do this black has
managed to control the only square on
which you can trade this Bishop if you
go back to traded in f8 the problem will
be once again that my bishop will move
and then I'll just make sure that
regardless on which diagonal your Bishop
will be I will be on the other one okay
so going back to the starting position
with Bishop and games of the same color
okay you have to be very mindful about
trading your opponent's Bishop and also
restricting their King so in this
position the simplest way to make a draw
is like I said we just take the pawn and
then we take if we want to try to win
this it might take us forever and
probably we will not end up winning it
you need to do something like this if
you want to win so like with the move
that we play it for black if you want to
try to win with white we need to kind of
keep black skiing restricted there in
the corner but still even so it's not so
easy so that's why we do the draw by
Bishop takes f6 okay so in this position
my opponent played Bishop h4 what did I
do
I only have one good move
yes
take the palm Bishop thanks again it's
not still mates right and thank you
promotes I go back yes and the idea is
that now your bishop and your King are
stuck to to protecting the pawn and I
will have this little trick of playing
Bishop g7 Bishop h8 and this is how I
make a draw you come back I come back
and you have no way to improve the
position of your bishop or King yeah so
this is how I was able to save myself in
this game okay so remember this if you
ever get a bishop and game especially if
you have two extra pawns you want to try
to avoid allowing your opponent to block
it your pawns with their King on the
opposite color than your bishop or the
bishops in general because if they do
and if they still have bishop movements
then it is going to be close to
impossible for you to take them from in
front of the pawn
okay because there is no no zoogs bank
right I got lucky here because I was
able to just make a bishop move back and
forth and this pawn wasn't protected so
this is another game that I played and
my opponent is a strong strong chess
player I believe he is a grandmaster and
he well I had this position I have black
here what is White's threat here
yeah to take the bishop okay so it looks
like in this position white is going to
be winning some material I have an extra
pawn though with black right okay
what did I do here
yes one of you
yeah
bishop TCH five-point xh5
Queen h4 well I'm just losing a bishop
and then I tried to trade Queens I don't
think that's the right way to do things
yes rook takes III okay so I sacrifice
an exchange not a piece okay
rook takes rook takes back guys don't
laugh it's a good it's a good
alternative right so what else what else
can we do here you remember I was
playing a stronger player Clare than
myself so you know I didn't if I lose a
piece I can already resign it's just
kind of bad Queen age for Queen takes
rook Queen takes rook yeah he takes back
rook III why he takes with the Queen
though right White has three pieces to
take back in history if you take me
three right why would he take with the
only one that loses material for him
no of course not you will take it apart
with the rook probably with the rogue I
mean definitely with the rook let's get
rid of those arrows those are not good
he will take with the rope so you have
some idea of what you want to do you
very well noticed this routine c7 is
only protected by the Queen
somehow it didn't say much today how
about them this side no okay look what
do we think about this move he has to
take back if he doesn't take back I will
take care too or maybe I will give some
chat I take this check and I save my
bishop and he plays this haha but he's
guys guys please focus his bishop is
protected if I attack his queen he will
take him his bishop will still be
protected what do I do here yes
nice Bishop takes age five I get rid of
the attack on my bishop I take another
pawn and I also distract his queen from
protecting his bishop so if it takes if
it takes I take what what kind of trade
look at this beautiful trade I want to
pawn so now I have three extra pounds I
should be able to win this even if it's
a super strong player right I might be
able to take f2 as well yeah yeah so he
played Queen h4 here he played he played
Queen h4 here and now I made another
good move because now both my bishop and
my queen are attacked so I played this
move
exactly I get this check I win the rook
and then it's over for them so in this
position my opponent played one more
attacking move of my queen what did I do
this gets really annoying check in where
in which on which square six okay what
if he comes back then I played this move
trading the Queen's training the quiz
because I didn't want to play queen g6
why I didn't want to play queen g6 for
example this is not passive why I didn't
want to play queen g6 think think here
my queen is the only one protecting the
bishop this is kind of like a hanging
piece because it's only protected by one
piece of mine so what does Y do here and
if I go here
yes this can be kind of annoying right
creepy okay if you want to call it that
way but the problem is you know how do I
save my bishop so that is the reason why
I thought okay I will have sufficient
extra material to be able to win this
game so I play Queen f6 offering the
Queen trade and I thought that if they
are going to trade which my opponent
didn't do but if they're going to trade
in this position a lot of people can be
tempted not to go into such a position
why do you think that is yes
besides the pawns I do have three extra
pawns here so I wouldn't mind that there
is something else that I could mind I
could be scared that I might not be
winning yes yeah
I don't worry about that because I can
play Bishop g6 I don't worry about my
king yes but there's no night it's just
because of some pieces around the board
what do you guys know about opposite
colored bishops what did you say well
when they're opposite colored bishops
you have some difficulty sometimes to
win a game because for example if you
have to pass pawns the opponent can
block it those pawns on the same color
as their bishop and you can't trade them
exactly and you can't change them away
from there because they just stay there
and move the bishop back and forth and
you cannot push the pawns and so
oftentimes a lot of people choose not to
enter Bishop endgame opposite color
bishops end games because they think
okay it's a draw but look there are a
lot of rules in chess that eventually as
you get stronger they will be broken I
mean not broken but like you will kind
of not respect them but that's as you
get stronger in the beginning you have
to listen to your coaches what they tell
you you have to follow that path and
then as you start getting stronger you
start understanding the differences and
when rules can be kind of bended a
little bit and and when you're actually
winning okay so anyway so my opponent
play Bishop g5 and I took here and
eventually ended up winning the game
I'll not I'll not keep going with this
because I have way too much material but
I really hope you you had something to
learn from this position now let's look
at this position just a second yeah
white looks much better okay I'm white
then wait wait King safety first and
material and let's try to figure out
what's going on here who is better
white because I played with white okay
my King is very safe okay
there is a file opened on blacks King
there's what yeah
diagonally what diagonally open
diagonals true there's this one for
example okay
yeah so what if they're next to each
other
and what is black threat hmm what is
black threat in this position to take
the night are you sure to take something
else yes yes yes take the rook guys guys
okay take the rook I know why my arrow
just disappeared
okay what do we do here with white how
do we start or continue our attack if
you think I'm attacking
yes check Bishop f4 check but when you
give this check you will go to the
corner probably and then what do you do
now your knight is attacked and the rook
is still attacked so yes rook to b3 okay
but what threats do we have in this
position the bishop is protected yeah
you don't really have threats I wanted
to start the attack here I want you to
bring my key pieces with temple and
everything what are the weak squares in
my opponent Kings position yes Luke c1
but the king is on the B file I played
this move yay sacrifice exchange
sacrifice oh I didn't want to waste time
moving my rook and then my opponent took
back right yes okay
[Music]
first
ouch ouch look at that look at this move
for a second to interview guys let's no
no look on the entire board I know but
you missed something you missed
something let's be nice to the the other
people in class kids are the kids
but I'm attacking guys in attack do you
trade Queens never only if you don't see
a good follow up that will lead to mate
yes so we obviously have this discovery
that can happen so where do we move our
Knight d5
I cannot go here why I cannot go here
Bishop f4
but we can do this move unfortunately
for you guys yes better better than that
Bishop c3 I think I can just maybe not
maybe yeah I can take right yes yes yes
yes one second one second
Bishop f4 indeed looks really great but
black has a defense yes but let's let's
do this sure
[Music]
I agree with you but the thing is I I
take and then you know I already
sacrificed an exchange with white so all
you're going to do with white now is get
your exchange back and me as black I
have an extra pawn in the end so after
all this doesn't really help you to win
the game right because you'll stay with
the point down Bishop f4 here allows
black to do something again because if
you consider that white has sacrificed
an exchange in the start of the position
now they can make this move you take the
Queen because and now they take your
queen and how is the material like once
again you take back with something black
still has an extra pawn okay so we need
to try to find something better than
that
so I played Knight b5 what what's the
follow-up like what's my idea so I'm
attacking the Queen
I'm also if you realize I'm keeping all
these 3 squares controlled so the Queen
cannot go on any of those squares trap
the Queen let's see let's see though
Queen B 2 is what my opponent played
what was the idea to have the knight
placed in b5 guys what was the idea yes
never mind do it
be confident what's the weakness what's
the weakness in blacks king's position
this nice move I don't know why I didn't
play it immediately I wanted to give the
check first because after this check
where do you go with the King in the
corner if you go here what's happening
and then
[Music]
it's not so simple
it's not so simple let's let's think
again what do we do here with white in
this position take in a seven I heard
that before
something else what do you think about
this move maybe
why not I have a big sir exactly I have
a big threat ninety seven checkmate
because I'm discovering my queen yeah
and I'm also I'm also bringing a new
piece to attack if you're not made with
two pieces alone I mean sometimes you
can okay but like two minor pieces is
usually hard to make the two minor
pieces so we need our Queen to attack
and then we're bringing our rook here
too and white will eventually mate or
wing a bunch of material so my opponent
when King gate after Bishop f4 King gate
okay what did I do
a four pony for Queen you need to
mention which piece is going otherwise
people will think I see a six yes King
a seven so that I avoid that discovering
because if I go here what's happening
don't I want to try to me mate okay so
my opponent liking a seven okay
pawn takes quite queen way what it is
why to move Oh what do we do
Bishop takes guys we want to play we
want to take here checkmate but it's not
right now because there's a pawn but if
we take here first then that can you
imagine if black needs to choose to make
this move bringing the king so much out
then it's definitely not so great for
them if they would have taken
okay so they play king b6 okay okay what
do we do now yes
yes Queen takes
yes
yes
this one yes yes what's your thread
after you take it
checkmate
so my opponent played this to stop the
checkmate
there are a lot of ways that you can do
this
I play routine 1x he took my bishop and
then I took so he gave me this check
rope do you want back and then I played
that I continued this way I was quite
happy with this position because the
king is just yeah let's see this beauty
I mean I'm happy I'm happy
well I hope so I sure hope so who is
better here white is better yes black is
clearly better and we have a knight in
this outpost this bishop is restricted
by its own pawns a lot of them can can
do excuse me
sure if it helps you you should be able
to evaluate the position regardless of
whose view you're seeing okay because
what are the characteristics that we are
using to evaluate a position before we
decide what to do first you look at King
safety then you look at material yes
you're looking at imbalances in a
position yeah but you start with King
safety then you look at the material
then you look at pawn structure so in
pawn structure you have to look at space
center and weaknesses right exactly
Fon Islands doubled pawns backward pawns
isolated pawns backward points pause
that are like behind from like and no
they have to be on an open file so for
example if blacks pawn instead of being
in a six would have been in before it
would make the pawn in a two a backwards
pawn
it's a pawn that's the end of a chain
and it is on a semi-open file from the
opponent's side so right now this pond
is six for example is a backwards pawn
for black because the D file is open but
look just because it's backwards it
doesn't necessarily mean it's weak -
okay so you can of course consider them
but you need to see whether they're
really weak and they are easily attacked
by the opponent's pieces if they are not
then they are not really weak they're
just fake weak fake seriously I mean you
can just count it that way anyway so in
this position since black is so much
better what do we do here with black -
to improve our position like to try to
win on the spot yes pushing the a pawn
would be a nice idea if you are not
having some tactical way to win here
serious let's be serious for a couple
more minutes
why is Bishop is trapped yes so what do
we do
G for guys
G for look at this beautiful move what
was i Queen takes e4 and this Czech
Bishop can you play King h3 it's not to
check my
why it would be a draw your night is
much stronger you can never win any of
my pawns what should we do here to win
with black we with this pawn in two
moves my opponent played this and then
King g5 and now king h4 I play it the
idea is after g4 all the white has put
another pawn on white he's trying to
bring his king and restrict mine from
entering so if in this position I pushed
I make the move king h4 what does he do
using somewhat of a sucks one yet the
bishop will never be able to move from
there because it needs to say to protect
the pawn and so if you play King g2 what
is my plan now with black to win yes
I pushed a5 first and then I took but
like obviously that is a nice idea
anyways very well done
so what about if in this position in the
start he plays this move take it what
what is it
are you winning the king and ponent game
why don't you just take the pawn very
simple take the pawn first and then you
can trade now don't you think makes a
bit more sense okay white to move in
this next position
exactly very well in this position I
have white and I was playing this in a
match between USA and India and I had I
was hoping I would win I had a really
good I played a really good game I have
an extra pawn here with white right so
what do you think I should do here so in
the game
my opponent took right because I just
attacked the bishop so in this position
we need to decide what to do with white
now the material is equal I have a knife
versus a bishop certainly I have the a
pawn which is doing which should help me
right it's a further away passed pawn
but my bishop my rook in a7 is attack so
I need to choose where I'm going to move
it and what my continuation will be I
can play what
if I manage to trade yes if I manage to
trade my rooks and my knight for the
bishop I should be able to win the King
and pawn and game because my pawn is
further away so by the time black goes
to grab that pawn my king will come and
win the endgame but it's not so simple
to get that right now right my king is
is Scott on the third rank although her
King is Scott - but my rookies attack so
I cannot keep it on seventh rank or can
i yeah no my rook is attacked rookies
haven't checked in d8 rook takes is six
that's what I thought I thought I would
just go take and then I have some chance
to win that anger but in this position
white can do something much better than
that which I completely missed to think
about and what is the follow-up of the
rook a a check
and then king 95 King g7e
seven yes this is what I missed
it's not so difficult 94 95 King there
94 and now white should be winning so
instead of doing that I messed up I
ended up giving this cheque and I took
the pawn because I thought okay I will
have an extra pawn I can always go back
to k-6 and I'm sorry she cannot take my
a pawn because they take our Bishop so
she played Bishop G one intermediate
move first though yeah it was a she I
told you we play the match between it
was a Women's World Team Championship so
it was USA versus India and I don't
remember what we did that match I think
we drew the match I think we drew it and
if I had won we would have won the match
but so stuff it was tough and if the
rooks get traded up yes yes well I kept
playing I kept trying but unfortunately
I wasn't able to win this this position
so if you miss this kind of pattern it's
bad so I thought I would end today's
lesson with something that I missed
because I know how much you enjoyed last
class the fact that I showed you a lot
of my losses and you know basically what
I wanted to show in these these lessons
is that you know you don't need to be
ashamed of your losses
if you or misses like if you miss like
here
instead of you know winning the game
ended up making a draw and you just need
to to always be ready to look at your
mistakes and see the positive side of
them and then try to improve from that
so anyways I hope you enjoyed my wins
today most was my wins right and yeah it
was good to have you here thank you
[Music]